So Leute, noch mal relativ spontan am Start jetzt.
Ich muss noch alles starten.
Ich habe noch meinen Vorschau-Rechner und so gar nicht an, aber der Stream braucht eh ein bisschen,
bis die Notifications raus sind, bis Twitch das gecheckt hat und so.
Das dauert ja alles immer ein bisschen.
Excellent.
So, ich kann meinen Vorschau-Rechner starten.
Ich habe da immer noch Skype drauf installiert.
Skype und Avira.
Ey, das ist so fail.
Wo habe ich die Crap überhaupt drauf?
So, gut, wunderbar.
Passt.
Ah, Teams hat wieder mal den Sound umgestellt.
Ich höre es direkt.
Lull.
Warum, warum, warum?
Alter, Teams.
So, äh, Recording.
Levels.
Na, okay, ein bisschen, ein bisschen umgestellt.
Nicht viel, aber ein bisschen.
Aber muss ja so sein bei Teams.
Ja, Leute, wie gesagt, ihr wart eben nicht da, wo ich es schon erzählt habe,
weil der Stream hat keine Notifications rausgeschickt.
Also, ich bin jetzt noch mal spontan on.
Wir basteln jetzt ein bisschen weiter an Preischamp.
Weil ich habe heute, äh, ups, ja, lull.
Weil ich habe heute, ich zeige es euch noch mal.
Der Preischamp ist am Start.
So sieht er bei euch nicht aus, bei euch sieht er so aus.
Ähm, und ich habe heute ein Analytik-Tool installiert,
was nichts trackt.
Also, ihr müsst da jetzt hier keine DSGVO-Anzeige rausmachen.
Es trackt einfach nur Seitenaufrufe, sonst nix.
Ohne irgendwelche Cookies oder, äh, IPs oder sonst was.
Es lockt von euch gar nix.
Und ich habe gesehen, dass seit heute Morgen,
genau, und Impressum, ganz anders steht,
wieso sind die nicht in Deutschland, ist auch nicht von mir die Seite.
Keck, weh.
Ähm, und ich habe gesehen, dass seit heute Morgen,
ich mache mal die VM kurz an,
ähm, dass seit heute Morgen waren 700,
180 oder so Leute drauf.
Dabei habe ich das noch nirgendwo gepostet.
Und ich habe permanent 5 Leute oder so,
die da drauf Preischampen.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, komm, bevor du morgen weitermachst,
kannst du auch heute schon weitermachen.
Und zwar, was ich dann die ganze Zeit machen will,
ist, dass wir eben noch die restlichen Dinger anzeigen, ne.
Also aktuell ist es ja so,
der Preischamp, und man kann sich benachrichtigen lassen, ja,
ähm, der zeigt ja immer an, wenn was Neues reinkommt.
Aber, ich meine, so ein Pop-up, wo einfach drinsteht,
welche Shops gerade was da haben, ist natürlich nicht verkehrt.
Da mache ich hier oben noch so ein paar Punkte,
da kann man draufklicken, Pop-up, Pop-up auf oder sowas, ja.
Und die eigentliche Preischamp-Seite ist jetzt auch,
was ist denn los, warum leckt denn das so?
Alter, ich mach mal kurz, ich mach mal kurz alles, alles zu, äh,
ja, okay, das leckt wahrscheinlich, weil das so lange offen war.
Weil das eine ist Java und das andere ist eine Javascript-Anwendung.
Da muss man sich nicht wundern.
Ich mach mal alles zu, dann entleckt's hoffentlich wieder.
Terminal kann ich aufmachen.
Ja, und, und, es hatte einer eine richtig gute Idee.
Man könnte UVP-Preise daneben schreiben.
Was haltet ihr denn von der Idee?
Ich finde, das ist eigentlich eine coole Sache,
dass man sieht, was es normalerweise kostet.
Ah, das war zum Testen hier.
Ne, ne, ne, das brauchen wir nicht.
Das können wir alles wegschmeißen.
Ist die Anwendung schon im Container drin?
Ähm, ne, aber das, ich hab mir noch einen zweiten Server gemietet,
für die eigentliche, also für die Nicht-Beta-Variante.
Ähm, da läuft der Tracker schon im Container und das Analytik-Tool auch.
Kannst du die Datensätze kaufen?
Kommt drauf an, was du bezahlst.
Prinzipiell kannst du bei mir alles kaufen.
Kommt, kommt, kommt nur auf den Preis an.
Okay, fast alles.
Genau, das hier wird,
das hier wird die normale Seite.
Wenn man da aktuell drauf geht,
kriegt man eine ganz tolle Meldung.
Wurde das im Streamer entwickelt?
Ein bisschen, ein bisschen.
Teilweise, teilweise.
Deswegen denkt dran, die richtige Seite ist die hier.
Ja, das, ich muss mal gucken.
Also, ich will da nicht so viel manuell reinschreiben.
Aber jetzt machen wir erstmal,
jetzt machen wir erstmal das mit UVP
und die Shops-Anzeigen.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Und morgen muss ich das ein bisschen modellieren.
Ich habe vorhin schon angefangen,
aber ich habe mir gedacht, ich mache einfach im Stream weiter.
Weil ich hatte ja bisher alles in einer großen Seite.
Guckt, ich hatte bisher
alles
Ich hatte alles in meiner
Main-App-Datei drinnen.
Die wurde
mit der Zeit ein bisschen
Sag mal,
warum laggt das denn so?
57%?
Jetzt geht's.
Was auch immer.
Vielleicht soll ich mal updaten.
was er für schmerzen hat brauchst du auch für paar tausend auch ein trojaner
ein wie die chinesen klar aber ein paar tausend reichen dafür nicht da musste
schon da musste schon ein bisschen mehr in die in die tasche greifen wenn ich
sowas einbauen soll indisch exzellent exzellent chicken beste
gestern auch hähnchen gefuttert aber nur notgedrungen ich wollte gestern
eigentlich chicken burger bestellen bin auf lieferando drauf kann ich jetzt
jetzt nicht zeigen weil dann muss paypal eingeben aber wenn man paypal eintippt
da kommt doch immer bevor man bezahlt noch mal so wollen sie auch wirklich
bezahlen die seite kennt er ja wollen sie auch wirklich bezahlen und da habe
ich irgendwie im kopf abgeschaltet hat mir gedacht ich habe schon bezahlt und
bin ein anderer
tab und irgendwann so 12 uhr 30 denke ich mir dann so einer das essen könnte
auch langsam echt mal kommen das essen kam als nett und irgendwann gehe ich
dann wieder auf die seite zurück von lieferando und stellt fest das ist immer
noch ein checkout prozess verkackt ja was weiß jemand aus dem chat wie wie es
aussieht wenn ich das charakter set von der oracle datenbank oje ich hoffe das
ist auch kobold software die darauf zugreifen keine ahnung weiß nicht so wie
gesagt ich hatte alles bisher in meiner
main app das das wird ein bisschen bisschen viel dass hier kann bei dabei
auch daraus und mose in die die com bonant rein
das Rainer
kos tester für onder welle
eda
Jetzt bauen wir erst einmal folgendes ein.
Erst einmal die Geschichte mit...
Oh, vielleicht muss ich gleich neu starten.
Schauen wir mal.
Erst einmal die Geschichte mit Pop-Up und mit UVP.
Ach Mist, ich habe hier lokal gar keine...
Allow, klar.
Ich habe hier lokal gar keinen Street...
Street Merchant laufen.
Dann muss ich das lokal...
Oh, ich habe geupdatet.
Okay, Leute, ich muss Update abwarten.
Der hat geupdatet gerade Elektron.
Oh no, da kann er nur in die Hose gehen.
Gibt es Vorteile oder Nachteile, C-Sharp.net auf Windows oder Linux zu programmieren?
Ich würde es nicht unbedingt jetzt so richtig hart Vorteile und Nachteile nennen.
Ich meine, .NET ist auf Windows entstanden.
Dementsprechend hast du auch noch viele Dinger, die nur unter Windows funktionieren.
Ganze WPF-Geschichte, ganze Windows-Forms-Geschichte.
Falls du dir UWP geben willst.
Das ist das Ganze natürlich auch nur Windows.
Ganze DirectX-Geschichten ist nur Windows.
Also sind einige Sachen, die sind Windows-only.
Also alles, was GUI angeht.
Aber ansonsten muss ich sagen, entwickle ich lieber auf Linux mittlerweile.
Also Server-Zeug auf jeden Fall.
Weil es hat Vorteile, die Sachen auf dem System zu entwickeln, wo es später auch drauf läuft.
RIS Downhange, weiterer Grund, warum ich nicht Dual-Boot sondern die Sache in der VR laufen lasse.
Also Leute, ich muss euch mal sagen.
Also während das Updaten ist, sag ich mal was.
Der SiriusMax, ich weiß nicht, ah, der ist gerade im Chat.
Der hat ein richtig nices...
Äh, Max, kann ich das im Stream zeigen?
Oder noch was?
Ich will nicht den privaten Chat-Verlauf zeigen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was da alles drin steht.
Hast du die Bilder irgendwo links zu oder so?
Dann zeige ich dir nämlich mal im Stream.
Der SiriusMax hat nämlich ein richtig cooles GUI gebaut für PriceChamp.
Und diese Seite hier, diese Übersichtsseite,
werde ich aber in irgendeiner Form lassen.
Weil, lustigerweise, es wirkt erstmal kontraproduktiv,
dass da nicht direkt das günstigste steht und so.
Aber ich habe gemerkt, das hat so, und jetzt lacht mich mal aus, ne.
Das hat so einen gewissen Gambling-Faktor, den die Leute geil finden.
Das habe ich in den Analytics gesehen.
Es gibt so viele Leute, die sitzen, obwohl ich es noch nirgendwo geteilt habe, das Ding eigentlich.
Die sitzen den ganzen Tag da und gucken da drauf, wie die Kästchen blinken.
Und, ähm, ich finde es auch insofern ganz gut, weil da steht halt immer genau das Letzte, was er gefunden hat.
Und, das ist insofern ganz cool, was du hier siehst, ist halt wirklich das allerletzte, was er gefunden hat.
Nicht unbedingt jetzt das aktuell allerbilligste, aber das Letzte.
Das heißt, wenn du hier hingehst, dann sind die Chancen gut, dass es auch lieferbar ist.
Guck hier, nur reins auf Lager.
So, und ich werde es dann so machen, ich mache hier noch einen Detailknopf hin.
Und, ähm, ich werde es dann so machen, ich mache hier noch einen Detailknopf hin.
Und, da sieht man dann den ganzen aktuellen Kram.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal das Design vom Series Max an.
Das ist richtig...
Gut, ähm, Firefox soll mal neu starten.
Haben wir es jetzt.
Genau, guckt mal.
Das ist das Design, was der Series Max gebaut hat für Price Champ.
Das Ganze ist DSGV-konform.
Ja, das speichert keine IPs, keine Cookies, nix.
Das macht im Prinzip nichts anderes, als, ähm, einen Post-Request schicken, einmal beim Seitenaufruf.
Das trackt nix.
Es macht einfach gar nix.
Im Prinzip das, was, äh, eigentlich schon eingebaut ist.
Guck mal, was er gebaut hat, hier.
Äh, ich weiß nicht genau, welche Reihenfolge wir das machen.
Aber ich finde, das hat er echt cool gemacht.
So, das heißt, man kann erstmal aus...
Man kann erstmal auswählen...
Ne, das...
Ich glaube, das ist die Ursprungsübersicht, seit wie lange was verfügbar ist.
Genau, die muss man auch noch ein bisschen anders machen.
Genau, da kannst du auswählen, was du alles angucken willst.
Und du kannst sogar sagen, dass du das jetzt nicht mehr kannst.
Du kannst auch sagen, welche Shops dich interessieren und welche nicht.
Also, das hat er echt nice gemacht.
Und vor allem die Detailansicht.
Ich glaube, das ist das Ding, was ich wirklich erstmal auch übernehmen werde.
Die Detailansicht hat er cool gemacht.
Vor allem, dass das Ding nicht einfach Verkaufspreis heißt, sondern Stonks.
Das muss später auch so heißen.
Ich hab Overclocker schon längst rausgenommen.
Ist nicht mehr drin.
Stonksverlauf heißt das dann.
Da machen wir auch den Stonksmann als Bild hin.
Ja, hat er cool gemacht, oder?
Sieht echt richtig nice aus.
So.
Jetzt muss ich mal lokal gucken, ob ich lokal jetzt das starten kann.
Ah, gut.
Geht wieder.
Sehr gut.
Das ist nur Prototyp.
Ja, ja.
Mit was hast du das gemacht?
Hast du da selbst HTML gemacht, oder ist das eher so Imagebearbeitungs-Markup-Mockup-Ding?
Adobe XD.
Das wollte ich mir schon lange mal angucken.
Habe ich nie gemacht.
Slay.
Da, Teddy.
Acht Monat.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Massive Subscription.
Nee, bezahlt werden Leute prinzipiell nicht.
Ich ja auch nicht.
Äh, ich muss mal kurz hochscrollen.
Ich glaube, ich habe nämlich Subs übersehen.
Kann das sein?
Leute, habe ich Subs übersehen?
Nee, ich glaube nicht.
Sorry, falls ich Subs übersehen habe.
Ey, was ist das View-Format?
Das, äh, wenn du View eingibst in Google, das erste, was du findest, ist das richtige.
Nee, Google Adsense brauche ich nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich habe eine eigene Sache, die das zählt und mehr als Seitenaufrufe und Seitenleuten, die aktuell drauf sind, brauche ich nicht.
So.
Also.
Äh, was habe ich jetzt gesagt, wollen wir einbauen?
Das, das mit dem Popup, ne?
Das, das in dem Popup anzeigt, was alles verfügbar ist, von welchen Händlern.
Ach so, du meinst Adsense-Werbung.
Hä, wie funktioniert denn das überhaupt?
Hat da jemand Erfahrung mit?
Kommt dann hier oben automatisch auf der Seite so ein Adsense-Ding, oder was?
Desktop-App. Easy.
Elektron-App.
So, also, wir machen jetzt erstmal einen Popup.
Weil, Leute, ich denke, hier den UVP hinzuschreiben, ist nicht so sinnvoll, oder?
Ich finde, die Seite ist eigentlich relativ gut, wie sie ist.
Das verwirrt die Leute nur, wenn hier noch irgendwie UVP dabei steht.
Ja, ich mache da auch ein Impressum hin.
Wie gesagt, ich schreibe da einfach mal einen Fader hin.
Der hat zwar nichts damit zu tun, aber der hat mich auch schon ab und zu mal ein bisschen gescamt.
Dann kriegt der das jetzt.
Nee, wisst ihr, was ich mache?
Ich habe mir das schon überlegt.
Ich schreibe da einfach hin, Impressum, Projekt bei Max FPS.
Und mache einen Link auf meine About-YouTube-Page.
Und gut, das...
Und im Zweifelsfall sollen die bei meinem Netzwerk anrufen.
Die wissen dann zwar überhaupt nicht, was Sache ist.
Da ruft da irgendwie einer an und sagt,
Oh, ihr Preisschamp, voll kacke, ihr Sack!
Und die denken so, hä, Alter, was?
Die E-Mail-Adresse steht auch auf der YouTube About-Page.
Also, passt.
So.
Also.
Mit was fangen wir denn jetzt an?
Wie gesagt, ich glaube, hier den UVP hinzuschreiben, sackt ziemlich.
Das würde dann so aussehen.
Ähm...
Ich sag mal so mit der Reihenfolge, wo ich hier bin.
Shop.
Price.
Äh...
Da wird dann irgendwie drinnen stehen, 1000 UVP oder so.
Ups.
Brr.
Keckweight.
Äh...
Ich und HTML.
Ey, wo ist das Problem?
Äh...
Wo...
Wo ist das Problem?
Ah doch, geht's, geht's.
Hä?
Okay.
Ähm...
Das ist kacke.
Natürlich könnte ich das noch ein bisschen größer machen.
Aber das sieht, das, das sieht trotzdem doof aus, oder?
Das sieht, das sieht trotzdem...
Ich meine, man könnte es vielleicht dahinter schreiben, weil da ist ja noch Platz.
Irgendwie so?
Aber so wirklich nice?
Ist das...
Okay, dann müsste ich es breiter machen, wenn ich das dahinter schreibe.
Ich finde das mit UVP nicht schlecht.
Ich finde die Idee gut, die schreibe ich auf die Details-Seite.
Weil dann weiß man, was das mal ursprünglich eigentlich sein sollte.
Ja, also in der Übersichtsseite finde ich das gut.
Ja, also in der Übersichtsseite finde ich, muss das, muss das echt nicht hin.
So, also machen wir jetzt mal einen Pop-up.
Ich kann übrigens immer nicht merken, wie das mit dem Pop-up geht.
Dialog, genau.
So.
Ähm...
Was mit der CPU-Last abgeht, das ist der, der Street Merchant.
Aber ich kann den jetzt übrigens ausmachen.
Weil ich habe die Zeit von 15 Minuten auf 60 Minuten zum Testen hochgestellt.
Prozentualer Unterschied zum UVP.
Das können wir alles auf die Detail-Seite schreiben.
Ich schreibe mir das mal auf.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Weil auf die Detail-Seite kommt aktuell nicht so viel drauf.
So, hier.
Bäh.
Ja, schon besser.
Äh...
Ruby.
Ich würde das mal aufschreiben.
Ja, das ist eine gute Idee.
Mach ich dann.
Das ist Latein, das ist Fake-Latein.
Das ist dieses, das ist dieses Fake-Latein zum Texte testen.
Das ist, äh...
Das benutzt, benutzt total viele.
Ist das ein Projekt von Max?
Das hier?
Das?
Ja.
Vielleicht ist das auch kein Fake.
Was auch immer.
Ist mir doch egal.
Ich brauche...
Ich muss einfach nur wissen, wie ich ein Pop-Up mache.
Ein ordentliches Pop-Up.
Oh, so Slider...
Slider...
Slider-Man-Pop...
Pop-Up.
Das Slider-Man-Pop-Up nehmen wir.
Das ist gut.
Dialog.
Excellent.
Copy...
Stack-Overflow-Driven-Copy-Paste-Programming.
Schreibe ich gleich in meine...
Mein, äh...
Lebenslauf.
Kenne mich damit aus.
So.
Wo macht man das jetzt am besten hin?
Pop-Up ist eigentlich egal.
Pop-Up ist eigentlich egal, wo das ist.
Okay.
Also...
Oh, wir brauchen erst mal Buttons, um das Pop-Up aufzumachen, hä?
Richtig agile, ja.
Moment, ich brauche einen Button, um das Pop-Up...
Ah, guck mal, da habe ich doch sogar schon einen Button, um das Pop-Up aufzumachen.
Das hatte ich mal vor einer Weile eingebaut.
Guck mal hier.
Wie findet ihr...
Wie findet ihr das da?
Zum Pop-Up öffnen für Detail-View?
Also, es gibt zwei Varianten, wie man machen...
Wie man das machen kann.
Ähm...
Entweder...
Das komplette...
Das komplette Ding öffnet das Pop-Up.
Außer halt der Shop-Link.
Oder sowas in der Richtung.
Weil das...
Weil nochmal Punkte oben macht es eigentlich fast schon ein bisschen zu überladen, oder?
Egal.
Ich mache erst mal das...
Ich bastel erst mal das Pop-Up, dass das gut ausschaut.
Das komplette wegen Mobile.
Ich habe es auf Mobile ausprobiert.
Also, Alerts zu aktivieren und deaktivieren geht auch Mobile ziemlich gut.
Übrigens...
Auf Android funktioniert es prinzipiell.
Habe ich bei mir auf dem Tablet probiert.
iOS keine Chance.
Die haben halt keine Notification-API.
Da muss man sich was anderes überlegen.
Für iOS brauchst du eine Native-App für Notifications.
Ich meine, ich könnte daraus easy eine Native-App machen.
Es gibt ja sogar Webseiten zu Native-App-Converter.
Aber dann müsste ich mich beim...
Müsste ich mich für einen App-Store anmelden und sowas.
Da habe ich ehrlich gesagt...
Keinen Bock drauf.
Ja.
Diese drei Punkte kennt doch jeder für mehr Info.
Ja, deswegen.
In dem Fall ist es eigentlich nicht schlecht.
Aber vielleicht macht es ein bisschen zu voll.
So, ich mache jetzt erst mal den Dialog rein.
Das Overlay.
Ähm...
Bla...
Was haben die da wieder in ihrem...
Was haben die da wieder in...
Ich bin verwirrt.
Die haben ja so viel Gedöns wieder hier drinnen.
Brauchen wir doch alles gar nicht.
Wir brauchen eine Dialog-Variable.
Das ist aber auch anders.
Eine Variable, das ist aber auch alles.
Dialog.
Ist true.
Wir wollen es ja standardmäßig anzeigen.
Und...
Ach so, ne, Moment.
Haha.
Nein, nein, wir wollen das garantiert nicht standardmäßig anzeigen.
Weil sonst habe ich gleich drei Pop-Ups offen.
Das will ich ja.
Obwohl.
Wurscht.
Können wir mal ausprobieren.
So, und wie sage ich ihm jetzt, dass er das aufmacht?
E-Model.
Dialog.
Nice.
Oh, ich habe wirklich 50 Pop-Ups jetzt gemacht.
Eine äußerst clevere Idee.
Excellent.
Perfekt.
So macht man es.
Wow.
Jawoll.
Poggers.
Und dieses Icon hat ein bisschen zu hohen Z-Index, würde ich sagen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das mit dem Z-Index gemacht habe, ehrlich gesagt.
Ey, Leute.
Was ist denn das?
Seht ihr auch, was ich sehe?
Ah.
Gehst du fort?
Ja.
Guckt mal das Icon.
Guckt es euch mal genau an.
Das Icon ist unterschiedlich groß.
Guckt mal.
Das triggert mich übelst.
Das Icon ist deaktiviert größer als aktiviert.
Seht ihr das?
Das ist ein anderes Icon?
Triggert euch sowas nicht auch?
Wir haben Bell-Outline und Bell-Cancel-Outline.
Wir brauchen ein anderes Notíematik.
Notification-Symbol.
Da kann ich nicht...
Nee, da kann ich nicht mit leben, Leute.
Das ist nicht so einfach, wie ihr euch das vorstellt.
Moment, ist das
auf live auch so?
Ja, also...
Ja, das ist live auch so.
Oh, okay, Bell.
Was nehmen wir für ein anderes schönes Notification?
Guck mal, wir können den Wecker nehmen.
Wir können Wecker an, Wecker aus.
Gibt ja zig Varianten.
Alarmlight off.
Alarmlight on.
Kreis mit Ausrufezeichen.
Nee, da denken zu wenig Leute
an Alarm.
Alarm, Alarm.
Alarm und Alarm
off.
Aber die sind auch unterschiedlich groß.
Nehmen wir das Hütchen?
Wir nehmen das Hütchen.
Wir nehmen Alarmlight off
und Alarmlight.
Ja.
Ja, das ist gut. So ist das schön.
So ist das gut.
Schon viel besser.
Oder?
Ah, yes.
Guck mal, es ist jetzt standardmäßig on.
Wait a minute.
Die Glocke sah schöner aus.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber die Glocke ist unterschiedlich groß.
Das geht nicht.
Kein Excellent.
Na gut, wisst ihr, was wir machen können?
Also, Glocke cancel
ist größer.
Dann machen wir das Normale.
Wie gibt man hier Size an?
40?
Oh, wow.
Dann machen wir das Normale einfach größer.
Oh.
24.
26.
Ha, guck mal, guck mal, guck mal.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, jetzt ist es gut.
Jetzt ist es gut, guck mal.
Ah, guck mal, jetzt wird sogar die Glocke hier kleiner.
Was ist, wenn man die auf Size 24 jetzt macht?
Dass die iOS-Noobs das auch treffen?
Ah.
Fuck.
Wow.
Okay, da ändert sich tatsächlich was.
25?
Ah, ich weiß.
Bin da ja noch.
Ja, ich weiß, ihr freut die Leute.
Denken sich jetzt alle, Max, was hast du für Probleme?
Was ist mit der Glocke?
Boah, das...
Okay, Leute, wisst ihr, was wir lassen?
Ich muss das jetzt ignorieren, sonst mache ich da 3 Stunden dran rum.
Wir machen jetzt Pop-Up.
Pop-Up, Pop-Up machen wir jetzt.
Also.
Wir machen das erstmal temporär,
diese Icons da oben.
Ähm.
Dialog ist FALSE, wenn wir auf die Icons klicken.
Dots.
Klick.
Dialog.
Gleich True.
Äh.
Guck mal.
Einfach mal reloaden.
Oh, äh.
Der Z-Index ist nicht so gut von dem Ding.
Eins.
Weiß gar nicht, warum ich den Z-Index hochgemacht habe.
Hatte das irgendeinen Sinn?
Irgendwas war da kaputt, glaube ich.
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr was, scheint so.
Hast du Ahnung, wie viele Words per Minute?
Nö, keine Ahnung.
Ist aber auch vollkommen irrelevant,
weil man sitzt eh zum größten Teil erstmal am googeln oder am überlegen.
Echt?
Es gibt nen Github-Issue.
Damit muss ich mir das jetzt angucken.
Bell Inconsistency.
Siehste?
Ich bin nicht der Einzige, den das nervt.
Guckt's euch an.
Das kann ja net sein.
Ja.
Wie?
Was soll das?
Erst, erstmal.
Ich muss Daumen runter geben.
Bin ich hier irgendwo noch eingeloggt?
Wo bin ich? Bin ich irgendwo noch eingeloggt?
Nee, hat er Glück.
Nee, ohne Outline geht nicht.
Das sieht, das sieht dumm aus.
Moment.
Aber das sieht dumm aus.
Die ist richtig, die ist richtig.
Die andere Bell aber nicht.
Aber die sieht dumm aus.
Das mit Outline ist viel besser, oder?
Sagt doch mal, das mit Outline ist viel besser.
Das sieht weniger, weniger gewichtig aus.
Irgendwie.
Erstmal YouTube-Video machen.
Okay, also. Wir machen jetzt erstmal das Pop-Up.
Das ist wirklich ewig rum.
Also, gut.
Also.
Was schreiben wir da rein?
Was, was, was schreiben wir da rein?
Der Chat macht Daumen runter.
Echt, habt ihr Daumen runter gemacht?
Leute.
Perfekt. So muss das sein.
Wow.
TechWait.
Ach so, ich hab's beendet.
Okay, der Dialog sieht kacke aus.
Guckt mal, wie dumm der ausfadet.
Wie sieht der so dumm aus?
Okay, das kommt weg.
Ja, so ist, so ist viel besser.
Äh, wenn der Dialog da ist,
der triggert die,
der triggert die Scroll-Leiste.
Und jetzt ist die Scroll-Leiste weg.
Ich sollte die Scroll-Leiste überhaupt noch ausblenden.
Zeit scrollbar.
Das braucht nämlich keiner.
Ist weg.
Ey, wenn der jetzt das Projekt quittet,
ich will nicht schuld sein, ja?
Ist immer noch da.
Ah, yes.
Gleich viel besser.
Ich hasse das, wenn Seiten rumzuckeln,
wenn sie eigentlich still sein sollten.
Und ganz ehrlich, eine Scrollbar,
oh, nicht hidden.
Nicht hidden, da kann man ja nicht mehr scrollen.
Ne, ne, hidden geht nicht.
Ne, ne, Moment.
Hidden geht nicht.
Ich will doch scrollen können.
Das wird doch so kompliziert.
Muss viel agieren.
Wie hab ich das denn bei Monarch S gemacht?
GitHub.
Wie hab ich das bei Monarch S gemacht?
Kannst du nicht die Icons manuell sicherlich irgendwie,
aber da hab ich eigentlich keinen Nerv drauf.
Aber da hab ich eigentlich keinen Nerv drauf.
Appview-Style.
Ah, HTML-Webkit-Scrollbar war es.
Ich wusste doch, das ging irgendwie.
Ah, yes.
Und jetzt kann man noch scrollen und die Scrollbar ist weg.
Und die Webseite zuckelt nicht mehr.
So muss das sein.
Sehr schön.
Exquisite, würde ich sagen.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir erstmal ein paar Infos hier reinkriegen.
Wie bauen wir denn das Popup auf?
Aber jetzt ist die Scrollbar weg.
Das macht nichts, wenn die Scrollbar weg ist.
Die Scrollbar brauchst du doch nicht.
Wozu?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Scrollt jeder mit der Maus gerade?
Du kannst mit der Tastatur scrollen.
Meint ihr wirklich, es gibt Leute, die Probleme haben, wenn die Scrollbar weg ist?
Hier ist das CSS mit der Scrollbar.
Die Boomer haben das eh im Fullscreen.
Und im Fullscreen ist das breit genug.
So.
Also das Popup.
Was schreiben wir denn da rein?
Also.
Wie hatten das da Serious Max gemacht?
Zeig mal her.
Das ist ja quasi der Detail-View, den wir brauchen.
So, mehr...
Ne, das stimmt nicht so ganz.
Ich will den Detail-View von einer Serie haben.
Als Verlauf Verfügbarkeit machen wir da nicht rein.
Das machen wir vielleicht oben als Grafin.
So.
Was machen wir da als Überschrift?
Ich bin immer so übelst unkreativ, was solche Sachen angeht.
Ähm.
Hier die Überschrift...
Keck weh
Stonks...
Kommt da als Überschrift...
Warum ist der...
Warum ist der Kart-Text denn so fett?
Wow...
Ich will eigentlich den Closebutton oben rechts an.
Haben die da ein...
Oben rechts
Das mag zwar nicht so
Oben links
Wie haben die denn hier gemacht, den Close Button
Äh, Button
Toolbar
Toolbar Button
Ich glaube die Musik ist vorbei
Hier, Toolbar Button
Button in die Toolbar
Okay, machen wir easy
Jawoll, okay, wir haben Close Button
Alles, da kann ich nämlich
Jetzt mal ehrlich, was ist euch lieber
Ein Close Button da unten in der Ecke
Oder oben links, ich finde oben links
Den Close Button, wir können den Close Button auch oben rechts
Machen, die Apple Leute
Wollen den bestimmt oben links haben
Rechts
Wie macht man das rechts
Ich glaube Spacer oder so
Oh ne, jetzt muss ich das jedes Mal anklicken, oh fuck
Äh
So macht man das bestimmt nicht
Heck, ich weiß nicht wie man das rechts
Macht
Auf jede Ecke
Leute, ich lasse den jetzt links, ich weiß nicht wie ich den
Rechts mache
So, okay
Was schreiben wir denn da jetzt sinnvolles rein
Ich glaube wir könnten es auf jeden Fall
Schon mal breiter machen, klar
Man kann, man kann übrigens
Auch sagen
Fullscreen
Dann kommt das so rausgestellst
Was meint ihr, Fullscreen
Oder lieber Overlay
Lieber Overlay, oder
Da siehst du nämlich noch ein bisschen was im Hintergrund
Passiert, du kannst auch hier hin klicken
Zum wegmachen, du kannst Escape drücken
Zum wegmachen
Overlay, Mobile, Fullscreen.
Oh, jetzt wird es advanced.
Mal gucken, was der Mobile überhaupt da draus macht.
Da kennst du ja nichts, Mobile.
Lull.
Ja, okay, Mobile müssen wir das wahrscheinlich Fullscreen machen.
Oder zumindest auf dem kleinsten
auf dem kleinsten Dings muss man es dann Fullscreen machen.
Was passiert, wenn ich die maximale
Breite rausnehme?
Ah.
Ja, das ist ja eigentlich noch besser.
Oh, ist gut.
Oh, bam.
Volle Pulle.
Da kann man dann auch sich den Graph angucken,
wenn man da drauf steht.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt was Sinnvolles reinschreiben.
Also ich würde vorschlagen,
wie mache ich das jetzt, dass ich nur mal einen Dialog kriege?
Äh, ich habe eine Idee.
Warte mal, Dialog gleich.
Ist das so, dass der alles anzeigt?
Genau.
Oh.
Ach ne, der macht es ja nie wieder aus.
Lull.
Okay, ich muss jetzt sagen,
ich will das nur bei der 3600 mal zum Testen haben.
Oder bei der 3900 mal zum Testen.
Info.
Serious Name.
Äh, 3090.
Ah, yes.
Okay, jetzt kann ich ihn zwar nicht zumachen,
aber das macht nichts.
Wunderbar, wunderbar.
Ich will ja auch nicht zumachen,
ich will aber was Sinnvolles reinschreiben.
Ich muss den Graph im Hintergrund übrigens wieder anschmeißen.
Graph, ja.
Nutzt du unterschiedliche Mäuse und Tastatur für den Linux
und den Windows PC oder einen KVM Switch?
Äh, das ist eine KVM.
Das ist eine KVM.
Das mache ich alles mit der gleichen Tastatur.
Okay, wunderbar.
Also, da kommt jetzt sowas rein in dieses, in dieses,
also der Titel, Titel ist schon mal eindeutig.
Da waren wir uns ja vorhin einig.
Stonks.
Jetzt ist es rechts?
Warum ging das mit dem,
warum ging das mit dem Button nicht?
Moment.
Ah, jetzt geht's.
What the fuck?
Aber wenn das so ist, dann ist das so.
Aber wenn das so ist, geht's nicht.
Hä?
Loh.
Äh, äh.
Ich hatte doch exakt das gleiche eben.
Can't wait.
Ich hatte den Spacer im Button drin.
Oh, da hab ich mich vertan.
Ja, kein Wunder, dass das nicht funktioniert hat.
Stonks.
Okay.
Äh, Moment.
Wie Toolbar Title, Title, Title, Title.
Alter, lade mal.
Ich weiß, dass im Hintergrund übelst abgeht.
Okay.
View Toolbar Title.
Vielleicht wird es da ein bisschen größer oder so. Mal gucken.
Stonks.
Da sehen wir alles aus.
Ah, guck mal. Stonks ist groß.
Perfekt.
Stonks. Close.
Jawohl. So. Also.
Und da kommt jetzt nicht Info hin.
Da kommt jetzt die Infos von
der Grafikkarte rein. Also Shops.
Das heißt, wir machen da jetzt
irgendwie so eine
Beautify Lists.
Oh, das können wir richtig, richtig
Unleashed
Triumph. Du kannst selbst ausprobieren. Geh mal auf
beta.preisschamp.org
Dann siehst du es. Und du kannst dir dann auch
live zugucken, wie es updatet.
Du kannst dich sogar übrigens
benachrichtigen lassen. Okay, was ist
denn hier eine schöne Liste? Wie können wir das mal
darstellen?
Ich würde sagen, mit so einem Avatar-Feld.
Wie gesagt, nachdem ich der
übelste CSS-Loop bin.
So, hier in der Richtung stellen wir das da.
Das ist, glaube ich, ganz
sinnvoll.
Hier machen wir das. Hier könnte man noch
ein Logo vom Shop hin machen.
Und da kommen dann
die Einzelheiten rein.
Oder so?
Ne, so machen wir es. So ist perfekt.
So machen wir es. Hier kommt der Shop-Name
hin. Und da kommt der Preis und der Link
und sowas hin.
Was, Ali?
Wie hieß der Typ?
Ist es Zufall, dass die Beautify-Sachen wie Android aussehen?
Nein, das ist absichtlich Android Material
Design.
Äh.
Muss ich da eine Row nehmen?
Ah.
Okay, copy-pasten wir das mal.
Äh.
Backweight.
Da ist jetzt ein bisschen wenig drin.
Ah, Moment.
Warte.
Ah, ich glaube, ich habe nicht alles kopiert. Wartet mal.
Hä?
What the f...
Was machen die denn da?
Ach, das hier ist die
ein... Das hier ist die...
Das hier ist die eigentliche Liste.
Okay, ich bin
hochgradig verwirrt, was
CSS-Shit angeht.
Und jetzt?
Wie ist...
Ah, gut. Sieht schon besser aus.
So, wir schmeißen jetzt
diesen ganzen Mist raus.
List-Item
weg.
List-Item weg.
Erstmal alles schön per Copy-Paste machen.
So, wie sich das gehört.
So.
So, genau. So wollen wir die Shops haben.
So, den ganzen anderen
Crap, der kommt auch weg.
Ja. Genau.
Ja.
Und da schreiben wir jetzt die ganzen Shops hin.
Sieht jetzt aus wie
Android-Kontakte. Ja, gut.
Die Icons und so kommen ja auch anders.
Anderweitig. Color ist mir erstmal wurscht.
Äh.
Gibt es ein schönes Icon
für den Shop?
Wobei, hier könnte man... Ohne Mist.
Hier könnte man eigentlich den jeweiligen...
...jeweilige Logo vom Shop verlinken.
V-List-Item...
V-List-Item-Icon...
Wo mach ich das mit dem
Avatar hin? Jetzt hier?
Naja, das geht ja nicht.
Äh, ich brauch mal...
Ich brauch mal ein Bild. Ähm...
Copy-Image-Address.
Ja, perfekt.
Source.
Da ist er!
Alles klar.
So, und als Titel kommt dann sowas hin wie...
...keine Ahnung. Äh...
Asus.
Oh, Leute. Moment.
Preisschamp Asus?
Stand da gerade was von Asus?
Hab ich das richtig gesehen?
Asus kann man jetzt mittlerweile direkt.
Okay.
Da fehlt noch Abstand.
Das hätte ich nicht gesehen.
So, ähm...
Also da kommt sowas wie Asus rein.
Das kommt dann alles untereinander.
Und hier unten kommt dann sowas wie...
...der aktuelle Preis.
Also sowas wie...
...sowas, hä?
So.
Kann man das da hin machen?
Ah!
Das ist aber nicht schön aligned.
Das sieht ziemlich kacke aus.
Ah! Ja, so ist es schön aligned.
So gefällt mir das.
Der absolute UI-Boss, ja.
Genau, und so.
Und von der Idee her wird jetzt...
Warte mal. Two-Line?
Was gab's denn noch? Two-Line? Three?
Three-Line?
Ja, Three-Line ist fast noch besser.
Weil da können wir unten drunter noch den Link machen.
Ne, den Link mach ich hier oben hin.
Das hat keinen Sinn, wenn ich das doppelt mach.
Sub-Header können wir noch machen.
Foul-List-Item-Conference...
Item-Avatar?
Oh, man kann auch was noch?
Header machen?
Ach, ne, hier.
Foul-List-Item-Subtitle.
Es gibt einen Item-Title und einen Sub-Title, den man nehmen kann.
Okay. Ne, hab ich doch schon.
Wow.
Wo ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen drei?
Hä?
Dass ich da noch den Sub-Header machen kann?
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen zwei-Line und drei-Line-Lines?
Hä?
Ist da einfach im Zweifelsfall mehr Platz?
Also könnte ich einfach so zwei Sachen nehmen?
Ah, da ist einfach mehr Platz.
Wobei, das ist bei dem anderen ist auch mehr Platz.
Two?
Ah, da ist das ein bisschen...
Okay, da ist das ein bisschen gestauchter.
Was findet ihr schöner?
Ich glaube, drei...
Ja, ein bisschen auch ein bisschen weiter auseinander ist schon nicht verkehrt.
So, und dann machen wir jetzt mal einen Link.
Äh, genau.
Asus.
Kekwee.
Wie sieht das als Link aus?
Brauchbar.
Ich will, dass das Kekwee-Icon bleibt.
Wir können da tatsächlich dumme...
Dumme Bildchen reinmachen, ja.
Okay, so würde dann ein Eintrag aussehen.
Allerdings...
Episi wenig, oder?
Ja, Schriftgröße auf Punkt erhöhen ist es, glaube ich, schon.
Wir könnten aber die Schriftgröße allgemein...
Jetzt allgemein ein bisschen klein, oder?
Naja, wir müssen erstmal die Logik...
Wir müssen erstmal die Logik basteln.
Also...
Wir würden jetzt ja nicht einfach da Hardcode und was reinschreiben,
sondern das, was verfügbar ist.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt erstmal von meinem Backend abfragen,
was alles verfügbar ist.
Dann sollte ich den Dialog...
Vielleicht doch als...
Einzeles Element machen?
Sonst lade ich ja auf einmal alles.
Das sackt ziemlich.
Na, wir laden einfach mal alles.
Das ist ja nur lokal.
Das mache ich dann aber später nicht so.
Also, ich habe hier schon was eingebaut,
dass man abfragen kann.
Und zwar...
Genau, man kann alle Shops abfragen...
Ach ja, by the way, ich sollte mein Passwort
und User in Passwort-Safe schreiben.
Ja, ja, alles klar.
Wisst Bescheid.
Genau, ich kriege eine Liste von den letzten Produkten
von jedem Shop,
wenn ich das übergebe.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus zum Abfragen.
Local Host 5000 CraftQL.
RTX 3070, definitely not POC.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hallo?
Also, jetzt müssen wir erstmal abfragen,
was wir haben wollen.
Schema.
Ja.
Also, wir wollen...
Query, History...
Oh, hab ich...
Aquary, genau.
So.
Also, History.
So, und da wollen wir jetzt abfragen...
Also, was brauchen wir?
Was brauchen wir bei so einer Status-Anzeige vom Shop?
Wir brauchen...
Ob es MSI ist oder sowas, ist erstmal...
Ja, warum?
Ne, das können wir schon anzeigen.
Weil aktuell lese ich da...
Alle Sachen aus, aber...
Was ist genau für eine Grafikkarte?
Das ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht so verkehrt.
Lass das Kek weh lachen,
wenn ein Artikel deutlich über der UWP ist.
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee.
So, Brand, Created brauchen wir.
ID brauchen wir nicht.
Den Preis brauchen wir.
Die Serie brauchen wir nicht.
Die haben wir schon.
Den Shop-Name brauchen wir.
Und die Url zum Produkt.
So.
Genau.
Exzellent.
Deswegen mag ich CraftQL mittlerweile.
Das ist total easy.
So einen Scheiß abzufragen.
Vor allem kannst du hier oben sogar noch...
Wenn man ganz hart drauf ist, kann man hier oben sogar noch filtern und sowas.
So, Serious.
Das Ganze nur für 30,90.
Zack.
Jetzt kriegen wir nur 30,90.
Der crawlt regelmäßig die ganze Zeit.
Was meinst du, warum ich so eine hohe CPU-Last habe?
Gerade lokal.
Ich sollte mal wieder ausmachen.
So.
Dann machen wir mal ein Query rein und gucken, ob es funzt.
Query muss ich mal kurz...
Abgucken.
Oh, was habe ich denn da gemacht?
Wir haben Stack-Overflow.
Stack-Overflow-Driven sind wir mal wieder.
Wir gucken, wie es geht.
Queries.
Oh, Data hat mich früher total zur Verzweiflung gebracht.
So sehr, dass ich nie wieder was mitgemacht habe.
CraftQL ist dagegen richtig, richtig...
Moment.
Richtig.
Aber richtig.
Okay, so ging das mit dem Query-Abfragen.
Wir machen jetzt hier gleich noch ein Loading.
Loading-Spinner.
Also.
Dann müssen wir das hier mal reinschreiben, dass wir das abfragen wollen.
Ging das nochmal hier?
Ja, jetzt...
Ja, ja, jetzt meckert er, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Ich weiß doch, dass...
Achso, jetzt muss ich das noch importieren.
Der Frontend-Boss ist wieder am Start.
Ihr habt es schon richtig erkannt eben.
So.
Gut.
Abfragen.
Hallo geht natürlich nicht, aber...
Unser Query von eben können wir nehmen.
Wow.
Missing world at...
Ach.
Also.
Sehr schön.
So, dann lassen wir uns jetzt mal unser abgefragtes Zeug anzeigen.
Irgendwo, keine Ahnung, hier drin.
Ist ja erstmal wurscht.
History lasts.
Ja.
Das ist das ganze Zeug, was der abfragt.
Okay.
Der fragt jetzt zwar hardcoded ab.
Für eine 3090.
Das ist jetzt aber zum...
Aufbauen von dem Menü erstmal wurscht.
Der fragt gerade hardcoded.
Das können wir aber später ändern.
Dass er das nicht mal hardcoded abfragt.
Der Nvidia-Sniper.
Ich habe schon überlegt,
wenn es verschiedene Crawler gibt,
die unterschiedlich gut sind,
könnte ich auch mehrere laufen lassen
und das alles ins Frontend packen.
Aber das Streetmerchen ist wirklich nice.
So.
Gut, jetzt müssen wir eine Schleife machen.
Über die ganzen
abgefragten Dings.
Also, wir machen das so.
Wenn das noch lädt.
Irgendwie kommt man sich das noch an.
Loading.
Loading state.
Genau, if Apollo loading.
Wenn das loadingt,
dann zeigen wir mal Loading an.
Loadet das überhaupt?
Ich muss kein Loading anzeigen,
so schnell geht das ja.
Gut, das ist ja auch lokal.
Und es ist ja auch nicht viel, ehrlich gesagt, an Daten.
Das können wir eigentlich weglassen.
So, also.
Das heißt, wir machen jetzt eine Schleife
über, vor,
äh, keine Ahnung,
ähm, was ist denn das?
Snapshot in,
äh,
Storylast oder so.
Oh, was habe ich
jetzt verkehrt gemacht?
Key.
Key gleich,
äh, Key.
Wow! Achso.
Ja, was hat der denn jetzt, was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen?
Äh, neben,
Shop, okay.
Okay, jetzt haben wir eine Schleife
über alle Shops, die
die 3090 haben.
Könntest du für die Noobs erklären, was da alles abgeht mit den verschiedenen Programmen?
Na, ich mache eine Website im Endeffekt.
Mittlerweile ist es ja so,
dass wenn man JavaScript Zeug programmieren will,
dass man erstmal das halbe Internet installieren muss.
Weil JavaScript Leute das gerne haben.
JavaScript Leute haben ja auch
npm Packages für
is even, is odd, das ist jetzt kein Wist.
Also, das ist jetzt kein,
das ist, das habe ich nicht vorher gesehen.
Ich habe das mal gepusht oder so.
Es gibt allen Ernstes ein JavaScript Package
is even, is odd.
Es ist ja nicht so, als gäbe es
keine andere
Möglichkeiten festzustellen,
ob eine Zahl jetzt
gerade oder ungerade ist.
Man könnte zum Beispiel eine Zahl
durch zwei teilen und den Rest gucken
oder irgendwie sowas, also
wir gucken uns mal den Source Code an.
is odd github npm
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal
den Source Code von diesem tollen
Das weiß ich nicht.
Wie da einfach in der Woche
450.000 mal runtergeladen wird.
Packagetales, von was ist es abhängig?
Warum ist das überhaupt von
irgendwas abhängig?
Ne, ist es gar nicht, nur def.
Also, huge source code.
Ja,
dafür braucht man ein eigenes Package, ganz wichtig.
Im Prinzip macht er genau das,
was ich gesagt habe.
Äh.
Ja.
Genau. Gleich 1.
Warte mal.
Warte mal, warte mal, Moment.
Ach, das ist Modulu.
Ah, jetzt habe ich es, jetzt habe ich es.
Also super, dafür braucht man natürlich ein Package.
So ist das JavaScript mäßig.
Die brauchen
30 Milliarden Pakete.
Ohne geht nicht, nicht möglich.
Äh, das ist übrigens falsch falsch hier gemacht.
Ich will das List Item generieren.
Das List Item
will ich generieren.
List Item
Jetzt kann man das
Ist das überhaupt richtig gerade?
Ähm.
Da haben wir es.
Ih, da ist ja wieder ein Scrollbalken.
Was denken die sich mit ihren 30 Milliarden Scrollbalken
da immer?
Wollen die einen Scrollbalken machen, sollen sie lieber das Popup komplett.
Äh, Scrollbalken ist,
Scrollbalken ist
Woodface, richtig Woodface.
So, das stimmt jetzt natürlich
nicht, was da steht.
Es ist nicht Asus, sondern
es ist
äh,
wie habe ich den gerade genannt?
Shop. Snapshot ist mir
zu lang. Das heißt jetzt einfach I.
Inf, nee, I. I.
Beste. Dass man immer
immer genau weiß, was es ist.
Shop. Okay, Mindfactory, Alternate, Computer,
Universe.
Äh, Capitalize.
Erste, da ist ja auch nicht eingebauten JavaScript.
Braucht man auch eine eigene Funktion. Das ist der erste
Buchstabe. Groß, jawoll.
Dankeschön für die Subs. Mäßig.
Fünf Stück, der Virus.
BLN, fünf, fünf Subs
gegiftet. Excellent.
Massive IQ Increase.
Dankeschön für die Subs. Wir haben was gekriegt.
KGaming.de, Tomba2612
Brombeerpilot,
xNiels
und mypsil.me
Excellent.
Und der Virus hat selbst nochmal abonniert.
Dankeschön für die Subs.
Hätte ich jetzt mal mehr Emotes, dann würde es
wenigstens auch was bringen.
Wenn man subbt.
Es gibt die Emotes, die sind äußerst poggers,
die wir haben, aber hätte ich mal von, hätte
ich mich da mal früher drum gekümmert mit Patrick zusammen,
dann hätte ich jetzt von 28 Emote Slots
nicht nur 8.
Also, Mindfactory, Alternate,
Computer, Universe, Overclockers,
Asus, Case, King,
Amazon oder wie die coolen Leute sagen,
Amazon. Ja, das ist doch als Popup
eigentlich schon mal ganz cool.
Was schreibt man da jetzt noch rein?
Moment, Moment, warte mal.
Was ich da gemacht habe, das stimmt nicht.
Was ich da gebaut habe.
Wir brauchen jetzt erst nochmal.
Komm, ich brauch mal einen gescheiten Namen dafür.
Das ist, ähm, das ist
weiterhin i.
Ne, nicht i. Stopp.
I, ähm,
das Datum muss da noch rein. Preis.
Preis.
Minus 1 ist es bei Asus.
Asus.
Asus ist es minus 1.
Warum denn das?
Das probieren wir gleich mal aus.
Warum es bei Asus minus 1 ist.
So, äh,
Shop.
Moment, Link. Link ist nicht
kekwe. Link
ist, haben wir ja, die
Url. Link ist i.url.
So,
und jetzt haben wir einen Link zu
Asus.
Okay, die Asus-Abfrage
gebadet einfach nur.
Asus Preis minus 1.
Wie habe ich das nochmal gemacht mit dem
mit dem Preis
Pixt 2. Okay.
Euro.
Oh.
Achso, das Euro-Symbol muss dahinter.
So.
Der sieht doch jetzt schon mal ganz brauchbar aus.
Das heißt, wenn man das hier anklickt,
dann kommt man zu den Shops.
Excellent.
So, wir sollten das noch sortieren.
Das Billigste zuerst.
Und wir müssen Preise rausfiltern,
die, äh, Minus haben.
Preise, die Minus
sind, wollen wir nicht. Das filtern wir
am besten schon im Backend.
Wobei, ne, das filtern
wir nicht im Backend raus, weil ich will ja trotzdem
anzeigen, dass die was haben.
Wir zeigen aber keine Preise an,
die Minus 1 sind.
Wir sagen, wenn das Minus 1
ist, dann zeigen wir irgendwie
not available oder irgendwie sowas an.
Kein Preis schreiben wir dann dahin.
Also, wenn der Preis
Minus 1,
können wir sowieso machen.
Wenn Preis
kleiner 0
Oh.
Wenn Preis
kleiner 0,
dann kein Preis
verfügbar.
Dass auch die Noobs wissen, was Sache ist.
Für sortieren kannst du die
Order By Pipe. Echt, sowas gibt's?
Moment.
299?
Warum ist da noch Overclockers drin?
Ich hab Overclockers rausgenommen.
Und es ist ein fucking
Ryzen?
Okay, mein Filter ist
kaputt.
What?
Ah, ich filter ja auch gar nicht.
Lul weh. Und, und?
Serious? Ja.
Ich hab gar nicht gefiltert.
Wieso nicht den Preis
erst anzeigen, wenn er über der OV...
Weil es kacke aussieht, wenn da kein Preis steht.
Du kannst davon ausgehen, dass der Preis immer über der OVP ist.
Nochmal laden.
Kein Preis verfügbar. Schau mal gut.
Okay, jetzt haben wir auch das Richtige.
Also, Moment.
Man kann da echt...
View, Loop, Order By...
Das hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Ey, das ist ja
cool.
Also ich muss echt sagen, die View-Leute
sind wirklich exquisite
Big Brain. Da kannst du nix
sagen.
Order By...
Was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen?
Wie geht das jetzt?
Hab ich das falsch gemacht? Was?
Gibt's nicht mehr. Ist weg.
You got rebadet.
Soll ich irgendeine
Custom Library verwenden?
Gut, ich mein, ist ja nicht so
als wär das...
Ich installier doch nicht irgendwelche komischen extra
Libraries dafür.
Ist das nicht sogar sortiert?
Aber ich kann das einfach im Backend
sortieren. Sort.
Ups.
Ne, äh, äh.
Sort.
Ne, Order ist das.
Ne, Order By haben wir schon.
Genau, Order By
Descending. Ups.
Alter, der Input laggt ja heute mal
richtig krass.
Da wird doch schon sortiert.
Ja, da wird sortiert
nach Created At.
Warum auch immer?
Ah, ne, ne, ne. Das ergibt schon
Sinn. Ich guck erst mal, ob die
Sachen innerhalb der letzten Viertelstunde sind, weil
danach sind sie nicht mal verfügbar, wenn sie gut
gefragt sind. Da guck ich, ob die Serie stimmt.
Dann sortier ich's,
dass das oberste
das oberste das letzte
ist. Dann
nehm ich mir pro Shop nur das
letzte raus. Und das, was übrig
geblieben ist, das order ich nochmal nach dem Preis.
Im GraphQL Query sortieren. Das geht wahrscheinlich
auch, ja.
GraphQL Sort. Das ist
ne gute Sache. Das probieren wir gleich mal aus.
Das hab ich nämlich schon drin. Aber jetzt müsste es auch schon stimmen.
Ja,
guckt, jetzt ist richtig.
Aber ich, ich, ich mach
das mal im GraphQL. Das interessiert mich, wie das
funktioniert.
So, wir machen das aus dem Backend wieder raus, dass es
wieder Shep ist.
Und wir gehen mal ins GraphQL und gucken, wie man das,
wie man das sortet.
Ja. Reloade
dich. Haben wir es jetzt.
Ja. Ne.
Jetzt? Hallo, warum darf
ich nicht da draufklicken?
Einfach reloaden, dann darf ich vielleicht wieder.
So, wie, wie sortiert man das jetzt irgendwie
sort? Ne. Hm.
Order.
Order. Die GraphQL
Syntax sah schon ein bisschen komisch.
Order by price.
Und jetzt muss ich euch noch eingeben, ob
desk oder ask. Desk.
Boah, ist das nice. Ist das nice.
Es ist so nice.
Das nehmen wir. Perfekt.
Bestes Query.
Oder Query. Query. Wie mein
Datenbanklehrer immer gesagt hat.
Das Datenbank Query.
Der Typ war eh geil. Der hat ja auch Datenbank
Datenbanken. Nicht Datenbanken ausgesprochen.
Da hat er immer gesagt. Datenbanken.
In der Datenbank.
Das Datenbank Query.
Ich kann das gar nicht nachmachen. Datenbank
Query.
Eine Umfrage vorschlagen.
Du kannst dir eine Umfrage vorschlagen, was dir
einfallen könnte das nächste Mal.
Und richtig rum. Gesortet.
Das Gute ist, wenn wir das so
sortieren, ist es. Hä? Ist das jetzt
Frontend oder Backend, wo er das sortet?
Sortiert er das
im GraphQL Backend oder sortet er das
nachdem er es bekommen hat?
Der im Backend wird sortiert,
vermute ich jetzt mal.
Also wahrscheinlich ist das, was ich hier gemacht habe,
exakt das gleiche, was ich vorher hingeschrieben habe,
was er macht. Ne, das war Babybert.
Ach ne, Frischkäse.
Ne, Frischkäse ist der
Beste im Töpfchen. Wie hieß der denn?
Wie hieß das denn? Dieses Fass.
Fass. Was meine ich?
Das da?
Ne.
Das war so ein braunes Fass.
Almette. Almette kann
sein. Almette kommt mir bekannt vor. Sowas hier.
Sowas in der Richtung. Ja, ja, Almette.
Was soll ich in der Konsole gucken?
Ach, du meinst, was zurück
kommt?
Ne, in der Konsole kann ich nicht gucken, aber
ich kann, kann gucken, was
netzwerkmäßig drüber geht.
Das ist schon sortiert.
Kommt schon sortiert an. Excellent.
So, also jetzt haben wir die Liste
sortiert. Das ist doch schon mal gut.
Was soll Maxi im nächsten Stream machen?
C++ oder Cobol? Warum gibt's
nur das als Option und nichts gescheites?
Ich geh schon wieder vorbei. Brauch was anderes.
Äh...
Warte. Mach andersrum.
Ja. Guck mal,
wie einfach das ist. Einfach so
rumsortieren und zack ist es andersrum. Aber
dann fängt's mit kein Preis an.
Kein Preis sollte eigentlich
unten stehen, oder?
Aber kein Preis ist minus 1.
Siehste? Da wird's schon wieder komplizierter.
Was? Ask
plus 1? Das funktioniert nicht, oder?
Ne.
Das wär's jetzt auch, wenn das funktioniert.
Kein Preis,
nicht anzeigen. Ja, nicht anzeigen
ist doof, weil vielleicht gibt's das ja.
Aber das sollte unten sein. Da weiß ich jetzt grad,
hab ich keine bessere Idee, wie man das
hinkriegt.
Okay. Wir brauchen aber noch ein paar andere
Sachen. Also, da soll ja nicht nur
drinnen stehen, wann,
sondern es soll auch drinnen stehen,
Verfügbarkeit.
Von wann es zuletzt aktualisiert
wurde.
Wenn wir richtig pro sind.
Wenn wir richtig pro sind,
dann schaffen wir sogar, dass es
live in dieser Ansicht
aktualisiert.
Dann muss ich aber hier draus, oh, das wird
advanced, dann muss ich hier draus
kein Query machen, sondern ne Subscription.
Dann kann ich das subscriben und krieg
dann, krieg dann neue Sachen.
Hast du mal was mit
influxdb gemacht? Ja, für mein Home Assistant
die, die Statuswerte
von den ganzen Sensoren und sowas.
Dass ich dann im Grafana
Übersicht machen kann.
Und Chat, wisst ihr, was ich noch für
nen Graf im Grafana hab bei mir daheim?
Gebt's zu, ihr wisst's.
Wenn nicht, muss ich's
euch zeigen.
Die Heizung, korrekt.
Die Heizung, genau.
Ihr wisst ja, ich hab
nen Dashboard für meine
Heizung, wo man sieht, was grad angesagt ist. Und heute
ist der ganz schön am Pumpen.
Ganz schön am Pumpen, die Pumpe.
Brenner ist auch am brennen, Temperatur wird aber gut
gehalten, passt alles, Kesseltemperatur sieht auch gut aus.
Status okay, Abgas okay.
Excellent. Heizung gemonitort, Heizung alles gut.
So, wir müssen
da noch reinschreiben.
Also, was meint ihr, Leute? Ist das
ne gute Idee, wenn sich das hier aktualisiert,
während man es auf hat?
Vielleicht ist es sogar besser, wenn
es sich nicht aktualisiert. Das verwirrt
sonst die Leute, wenn das hier permanent
rumspringt.
Vielleicht ist das Sortieren nach Zeit
auch besser und nicht nach Preis.
Ja, das
kann ich machen, aber das müsste ich machen, bevor
das hier,
bevor ich das
in die Schleife fütter.
Kannst du das mal
wann anders ausführlich zeigen? Ja,
kann ich machen.
Okay, also, jetzt zeigen
wir erst nochmal Subtitle.
Subtitle
zeigen
wir jetzt nochmal
Created Ad
an.
Da sehen wir nämlich
wann es angelegt wurde.
Ach, nicht Preis.
Da sehen wir nämlich, wann es angelegt wurde.
Oh ja, bester Timestamp.
Damit kann natürlich jeder was anfangen.
Okay, das ist jetzt nicht, noch besser.
Noch besser, jetzt kann man es noch weniger lesen.
Was jetzt?
Oh ne, es ist nicht to local time,
es ist to local time
string.
To lokale.
Alter.
Okay, das mit AM und PM
sieht bei euch dann anders aus.
Ich habe ja meinen Browser auf Englisch stehen.
Da sah ich mit der Musik gerade los.
So.
9.37, also 21.35 Uhr.
Ich meine, vielleicht ist es auch
sinnvoller, das nach Zeit zu sortieren.
Was meint ihr? Nach Zeit oder nach Preis?
Ich würde sagen, nach Preis.
Nach Preis. Und unten drunter kannst du dann
anzeigen lassen.
Weil, sag mal so,
das Ding zeigt eh nur an,
was die letzten 15 Minuten,
also verfügbar ist es eh nur, wenn es die
letzten 15 Minuten da
war.
Ansonsten ist der Shop gar nicht in der Liste.
Also 15 Minuten ist cut.
Wenn es innerhalb von 15 Minuten nicht erneut
gecrawled wurde und okay ist,
fliegt es raus.
Aber so wirklich schick finde ich das immer noch nicht.
Aber das, ähm,
brauchen wir auf jeden Fall nochmal.
Jo.
Oh, Divider.
Dass es da ein schönes Strich unten drunter gibt.
Hä? Ach ne, Moment.
List Item.
Ha! Das funktioniert gar nicht.
Ich muss da doch ein Div drum rum machen.
Wo ist das?
Ich muss das doch in Div machen.
Div?
Was ist das eigentlich für exquisite
Musik, die da dudelt?
So!
Okay, sieht schon besser aus.
Darfst du die Emotes einfach so
verwenden? Ich glaube, da kräht
kein Hahn danach, ob ich da einen
keck W-Mann mit
Mütze anzeige oder nicht.
Kann man den Avatar vielleicht auch
eckig machen?
Rounded.
Teil. Teil.
Dann ist es, dann ist es eckig.
Oh, viel besser, Leute. Viel besser.
Der muss eckig sein, oder?
Dass man ihn auch erkennt.
Wisst ihr was? Ich geb einfach in der Config
jedem Shop ein eigenes Emote.
Und dann, dann
sind unterschiedliche, sinnloserweise
unterschiedliche Emotes da am Start.
Das sieht doch lustiger aus.
Ich mein, das ist auch die Stonks-Anzeige.
Ach ja, wir müssen auch reinschreiben, was man
sich hier übrigens überhaupt anguckt.
Fällt mir gerade auf.
Also, das hier ist nicht nur Stonks.
Das ist Überschrift.
Äh.
Bäh.
Äh. Wie war das?
V-Card-Title?
War das so?
Ah ja, genau.
Schö. Schö ist was anderes jetzt.
Bin ja nicht so der Frontend-Champion.
Emojis auf den Preis-Mappen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Abweichend.
Emojis abweichend vom
UVP.
Ja, das ist witzig.
Emojis abweichend vom UVP.
Am Ende, am Ende kommt dann der hier.
Wenn du eine feste, ablaufende
Zeitspanne hast, dann mach doch irgendwie eine
Uhr hinter.
Oh, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt. Massive, Alter.
Das ist dann wie bei so einer
Gambling-Seite, wo die Leute dann
draufklicken müssen. So nach dem Motto, gleich läuft's ab.
Gleich läuft's ab.
Stimmt, wir machen den Namen
oben rein. Das ist besser.
Nicht stonk, sondern den Namen
rein. Ja.
Ich könnte noch pretty long machen.
Also.
Nicht den hier, sondern
schöner Text
mit, da könnte ich nämlich hier oben schreiben.
Da könnte ich nämlich hier oben reinschreiben.
Ähm.
Nvidia
RTX
3090.
Das machen wir jetzt noch. Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Äh.
Sirius.
Oh, da muss ich aber neu starten.
Äh.
Long Gachibuzz.
Wobei, weißt du was, da missbrauche ich
jetzt einfach Description für, wenn gut ist.
Wie heißt das Ding offiziell?
Nvidia RTX
GeForce 3. Ich kann...
Wie nennt man das Teil?
Ge... Ne.
Nvidia GeForce RTX
30... Jetzt schreiben sie alles
groß auf einmal.
Das TM mache ich da nicht dahinter.
Und by the way, wisst ihr, dass sich das live
updatet?
Schreibt das jetzt hier dahinter.
Dann sendet er das ans Frontend.
Und schon kann ich es verwenden.
Description.
Ach, Moment. Das ist ja auch...
Ha! Keck weh, das ist ja auch die 3060.
3060 TI.
Schreibt man TI so?
Ja.
Guck da! Bam! Hat sich automatisch geupdatet.
Da schickt das, da schickt das immer wieder...
Moment, wenn sich
das automatisch updatet...
Ah ne, die anderen
Sachen updaten sich aber nicht automatisch, ja.
Okay, das ist schon mal nice.
Gibt es nen...
GPU Icon?
GPU?
Extension Card?
Ich will mal kurz gucken, wie das aussieht.
Sieht wahrscheinlich kacke aus.
Äh.
GPU Icon.
Icon.
MDE.
Oh.
Hm.
Das sieht auch gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Preisschamp darf?
Preisschamp kann auf Mindfactory zugreifen.
Größer?
Ach Moment, ist der Close Button.
Äh.
Was passiert eigentlich?
Warte mal, ich probier mal was, Leute.
So?
Was meint ihr?
So oder in die Mitte?
Oder mal hinten dran probieren?
Oder mal...
Mitte...Excellent.
So lassen wir das.
Sehr schön.
Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, wie ich das mit dem Asus-Preis mache.
Weil der Asus-Preis soll unten hin.
Aber das ist jetzt erstmal nicht unser Problem.
Was jetzt noch cool wär...
Senpi, was
würdest du denn vorschlagen?
Ich find's auch nicht so toll, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ich mein, es geht ja jetzt das erste Mal.
Aber das, was der Serious Max gebaut hat, ist eindeutig schöner.
Das sieht so leer aus.
Da fehlt dann auch bissl was.
So, GraphQL ist doch der neue Scheiße.
Also Preisverlauf
können wir hier oben hin machen.
Verfügbarkeit-History
juckt wahrscheinlich niemand.
Weil was interessiert mich, ob das vor zwei Wochen
mal verfügbar war.
Aber ne Price-History wär glaub ich ganz praktisch.
Die Items ohne Preis vielleicht
in einer zweiten Section nach unten.
Eigentlich keine schlechte Idee.
Oder wir machen...
Ach, weißt du was?
Du hast recht.
Ne, ich mach's in einer, aber
Computed Property klingt sinnvoll, ja.
Dann machen wir nämlich...
Ja, ja.
Läuft das auf Netscape?
Wir haben's letztens auf dem Internet Explorer funktioniert.
Geht nicht.
Eine Verfügbarkeits-Graph wär schon geil,
aber nur für jeden einzelnen Shop?
Soll...
Naja...
Ich glaub, wir haben hier
ein hübsches
Schiffslibrary, wo man neben anklicken kann, was man haben will.
Guck hier, in Grafana geht das ja auch.
Wenn man in Grafana mehrere Sachen hat...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das hier hab.
Ne, hab ich nicht.
Da kann man auch hier unten anklicken.
Also, wenn man mehrere Sachen hat.
Ob man das sehen will oder nicht.
Das gibt's bestimmt eine fertige JavaScript-Graph-Library.
Mach die Zeit nach unten rechts.
Problem ist...
Wir haben ganz schön viel Platz hier.
Vielleicht sollte ich's doch nicht so groß werden lassen.
doch maximum 400 also habe ich jetzt an der falschen stelle gemacht da muss ich
es machen ich meine wir auch eine möglichkeit das
ist bei mir daheim ja ja dass das hier ist max hier gemacht ja dass das ist
natürlich schon mal viel viel nicer verfügt ach guck mal ja das ist das ist
eigentlich so ist eigentlich auch cool oder aber gut bild kann ich nicht
anzeigen lassen so ohne weiteres da müsste ich mir für jedes produkt was ich
rein was ich da rein machen ein bild raussuchen
ich meine ich könnte bild voller 30 90 rein machen aber übrigens was wir ganz
vergessen haben bei main factory ist es ja gar nicht mit 30 90 ich weiß ja sogar
welche 30 90 das ist bild vom shop ziehen die bild vom shop ziehe ich nicht
wenn ich ein bild von dem shop ausliefern
regen sie sich eventuell darüber auf ich könnte aber verlinken auf das auf
das logo bei denen aber ich will lieber ich will lieber im maus haben davor
ok dann probieren wir das mal aus 30 also ich weiß ja noch was es für eine ich
weiß ja auch noch was es für eine karte ist und zwar oder gucken ob ich das hier
drin stehen habe brand ist das glaube ich also genau das ist nämlich der
hersteller von der karte der hersteller von der karte der hersteller von der
karte weiß der auch weiß der noch mehr darüber erwartet einst muss ich mal
kurz kommen wir gucken mal der weiß sogar ob das was das für ein fastes für
ein modell ist wenn edge oc es ist nicht es ist nicht preis jump.org es ist
beta punkt preis jump.org preist wenn ihr auf preis jump.org geht dann gibt es
kappe 123
Warte mal, hat der noch was? Das speichere ich mir, glaube ich, gar nicht.
Serious? Nein, das speichere ich.
Okay, das habe ich nicht in der Datenbank drin stehen, dann kann ich das nicht verwenden.
Aber das Brand könnte man, das könnte man da eigentlich noch da hinten irgendwo anzeigen, ne?
Ach, wobei, wir müssen es nicht übertreiben.
Ich meine, juckt das wirklich irgendjemand, welcher Hersteller die Grafikkarte ist?
Wenn die Leute sehen, in 17, da klicken sie einfach drauf, sehen, ah, das ist eine Wassergekühlte, die will ich nicht.
Und wir dürfen nicht vergessen, umso mehr Link-Klicks, umso mehr Link-Klicks, falls ich da mal Ref-Links mache.
Okay, na, wenn ihr das wissen wollt.
Mir fällt übrigens gerade ein, ein Shop kann durchaus mehrere im Angebot haben.
Das wird ein bisschen zu kompliziert.
Das artet schon.
Wieder aus.
Weil es könnte ja sein, dass, warum ist der Aufwärtsglocker so überhaupt noch dabei?
Die habe ich doch rausgeschmissen.
Aber mir lokal habe ich die nicht rausgeschmissen.
Mache ich jetzt mal.
Äh, der checkt.
Kann der Notebooks, konnte, konnte der Notebooks billiger?
Ach so, ja, Moment, das ist das, was ich lokal habe.
Ähm, ich glaube, online habe ich mehr.
Sag mal, werde ich jetzt wieder gededost?
Sobald ich die IP zeige.
Ist der DDoS raus oder was?
Guckst du euch an?
Das ist doch ein Witz, oder?
Das ist immer abends, wenn ich striebe.
Komisch, ja.
Aber ich habe das schon hinter Cloudflare umgezogen.
Moment, ich bin ja schon Poggers.
So, so, Botnet ist wieder am Start.
Also, ne, Note nehmen wir schon.
Also, Mindfactory, Alternate, Case King, Computer Universe, Equipper, Media Markt, Saturn.
Nvidia selbst haben wir nicht.
Also, wir gucken mal, ob das überhaupt Nvidia selbst kann.
Trojaner schon installiert, easy.
Erstmal SSH-Key geknackt.
So, was für Shops kann der Kram?
Kann der Nvidia selbst?
US.
Nvidia, Nvidia, API.
Ah, man trägt da Country-Jar.
Wo ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Nvidia, API und Nvidia?
Ja.
Nvidia, API geht über irgendeine Schnittstelle.
Nvidia crawlt die Seite wahrscheinlich.
Ja, was ist denn da besser?
Keine Ahnung.
Machen wir noch dabei.
Crawler ausmachen.
Ist ja gut.
Geh aus.
Hier, der DDoS ist wieder raus.
Seht ihr das hier?
Das ist schon komisch.
Immer, wenn ich mich da im Stream drauf connecte, ist jemand lustig.
Oder es hat trotzdem irgendwas damit zu tun, dass ich da eingeloggt bin?
Ich habe es gesehen, es hatte irgendwie 150.000 Packages.
Die Kekomrits sind wieder weg.
Jetzt sind sie wieder drauf.
13 Dankeschön für die 16 Monate.
Massive Subscription.
In der Notebooks Billige habe ich drauf, ja.
Leute, das ist kein Zufall.
Irgendjemand hat sein Russen-Botnetz immer am Start, wenn ich das im Stream zeige.
Oder das ist Hetzner selbst.
Nvidia.
Nvidia, API.
Wollen wir einfach mal beides reinschreiben?
Nee, komm, Nvidia, API.
Funktioniert das auch was?
Cloudflare.
Nee, die Seite ist ja noch nicht hinter Cloudflare.
Beta-Preis-Champ ist nicht hinter der IP-Rate-Limit.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das...
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt gar keinen Bock, das zu analysieren.
Ich mache einfach Cloudflare dafür und gut ist.
So, Country brauchen wir noch.
Germany.
Ist schon komisch, dass das immer im Stream kommt.
Sehr, sehr merkwürdig, oder?
Ich meine, dass ich live streamen soll, kann es ja schlecht dran liegen.
Ist das wirklich nur im Stream?
Ja.
Also, wenn ich auf den Graph gucke, ist das nur im Stream.
Okay.
Start.
Aber der sollte sich jetzt wieder starten.
So, läuft wieder.
Gucken wir auf der Preis-Champ.
Was für eine Bandbreite.
Oh, einige.
Soll ich euch nochmal die Hetzner-Crafts zeigen?
Da muss ich euch einmal kurz ausmachen und mich einloggen.
Ich habe ja mittlerweile auch zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung an und sowas.
Warte mal.
Warte.
Warte mal, ich logge mich mal kurz ein.
Dauert kurz, weil das Passwort ist recht lang.
Okay, ähm.
Äh, OTP.
Jetzt muss ich noch meine Authentifizierungs-App aufmachen.
Aber, Two-Factor-Authentifizierung.
Okay, so.
Ich bin eingeloggt.
Cloud.
Also, ich zeige es euch mal.
So.
Also, das sind die zwei Kästen.
Ähm.
Ich mache da noch eine...
Eine Cloudflare-Protected-Kiste.
Weil, die kann ich ja schlecht nehmen, wenn man die IPs sieht.
So, ähm.
Beziehungsweise, ich mache einfach...
Nö, ich behalte die eine und mache eine andere IP.
Also.
Ähm.
Crafts.
Auffällig.
30 Tage sind viel.
Machen wir 24 Stunden.
24 Stunden Hetzner, auf geht's.
Ist schon sehr auffällig.
Ist schon sehr auffällig, oder?
Wann das immer auftritt?
Wann war eine Woche?
Was?
Okay.
Hetzner.
Mach mal.
Hetzner mag nicht mehr.
Kann auch einfach Wartung sein.
Hm.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Das ist schon auffällig.
Ey, ich meine, das kommt schon...
Ist schon sehr merkwürdig hier, ne?
Was ich aber merkwürdig finde, dass das überhaupt die Kiste zum Abkacken bringt.
War das jetzt eine Week?
Hm.
Oder vielleicht dedosst mich doch keiner?
Guckt mal.
Das ist auch...
Das ist auch nachts irgendwann.
Nee, es sind...
Ich meine, es sind 100.000 Package per Second.
Das ist unglaublich viel.
Und es ist Out-Traffic.
Aber warum ist der Out-Traffic...
Warum ist der Out-Traffic manchmal einfach so hoch?
Der Server dedosst sich selber?
Das ist die neue...
Das ist die neue Freund-Selliert bei Hetzner-Taktik.
Der Server dedosst andere, genau.
Komisch.
Mein Botnet.
Fuck, jetzt ist es raus.
Es ist aber schon...
Aber guckt mal hier, das ist...
Aber es geht auch mit Network.
In.
Also eigentlich, Leute, eigentlich hätte ich erwartet,
dass der Traffic...
Dass der Traffic in höher ist.
Weil Traffic in ist ja die Antwort beispielsweise auf mein Crawling-Zeug.
Guckt mal, 12 Stunden.
Alter, Hetzner, komm mal.
Lad, lad, lad den Craft, ey.
Guck, normalerweise ist In auch immer höher.
Aber ab und zu...
Out-Traffic.
Warum ist der Out-Traffic so hoch?
Was macht der denn ab und zu?
Aus welchen Gründen auch immer sollte ich denn auf einmal...
100.000 Packages Out-Traffic haben?
Das ist der, das ist der Richtige, ja, ja.
Aber, aber, aber, aber Out-Traffic...
Wirklich nicht.
Guck mal, wir hatten, wir hatten vor einer Woche, ging es mal richtig ab.
Vor einer Woche, da, da hatte Hetzner Probleme hier.
Aber da sind auch nur 60.000.
Die Anzeigen sind irgendwie sehr merkwürdig.
Hä?
Der Craft sieht jetzt wieder komplett anders aus.
Warte mal, 12, 12 Stunden hatten wir eben.
Moment, war ich eben auf dem falschen Server?
Ich, ich war doch auf dem richtigen Server eben.
Hä?
Bin ich...
Aber guck mal jetzt.
Moment, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Warum sehe ich bei einer Stunde die Packages auf 50.000 und auf 12 Stunden nicht?
Ach so, weil das nur bis 20...
Ne, doch.
Sag mal, bin ich jetzt total bescheuert?
Wir haben das doch eben selbst gesehen zusammen im Stream.
Ihr habt es doch auch gesehen, oder?
So, ich mache keinen Backup.
Wer braucht Backup?
Backup overrated, she baited.
Okay, Max.
Guckt mal.
Hä?
Was?
Moment, das war jetzt, das war jetzt PP...
Ach, war das einfach ein Network?
Network-Traffic, den ich geguckt habe?
Ja.
Hier.
Seht ihr es?
Das ist der Server?
Und...
Die, die Crafts bei Hetzner ergeben überhaupt keinen Sinn?
Warum zeigt das unterschiedliches Zeug an?
Kann das sein, dass es doch...
Dass ich weder DDoS-e noch mein Server was hat, sondern dass Hetzner irgendwas...
Das war jetzt gerade live.
Guck mal, jetzt ist es wieder.
Ne.
Moment, was?
19 Uhr?
Das sind jetzt 24 Stunden.
Ja, so würde ich, so würde ich erwarten, dass das aussieht.
So würde ich erwarten, dass das aussieht.
Dass ich hauptsächlich Input-Traffic habe.
Checkt es nicht.
Ah ja, okay.
Äh, die, die Crafts sehen jedes Mal anders aus, wenn ich mir die angucke, oder?
Das sieht jedes Mal anders aus, wenn ich mir die Crafts angucke.
Okay, was auch immer.
Was auch immer.
Leg ich nicht.
Aber so würde ich erwarten, dass das aussieht.
Und by the way, was auch sehr komisch ist, wenn ich auf eine Woche gehe,
dann sehe ich, dass es nicht so gut aussieht.
Dann taucht es hier gar nicht auf, wenn ich auf 24 Stunden gehe.
24 Stunden auch nicht.
Sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Das verwirrt mich echt hardcore.
Doch, Beta-Preis-Champ hat, hat, äh, IPv6-Einträge.
Doch, doch, haben wir gemacht.
Äh, by the way.
Wie ausgelastet ist das Ding?
Genau eigentlich.
Also jetzt haben wir Nvidia auf jeden Fall auch noch dabei.
Gut, ich mach mal wieder zu.
Also, das war's.
Danke für's Zuschauen.
Und, ähm, tschüss.
Auf Wiedersehen.
So, eine Sache machen wir jetzt noch.
Ich wollte es zumindest mal fertig machen.
Wo sind wir jetzt gerade stehen?
Wo sind wir denn davor stehen geblieben, Leute?
Es ist nämlich schon spät.
Ich geh gleich pennen.
Äh, das haben wir gemacht.
Das sieht eigentlich ganz nett aus.
Man hat hier die Anzeige.
Was ist denn bisher der Changelog für heute?
Ha, eigentlich haben wir nur das Pop-Up gemacht.
Ähm.
so
genau, stimmt, stimmt, ich wollte noch
einblenden, der
das Brand
wo machen wir, wo blenden wir denn
den Grafikkartenhersteller ein
die Sache ist, die eigentlich
müsste man da noch mehr machen, weil es könnte
ja sein
was, das hat keine IPv6
Einträge
dann hab ich's bei Cloudflare
vielleicht verkackt
ähm, ja
preischamp.org hat IPv6, weil es
Cloudflare ist, das passt
so, was ich aber nicht verstehe
ist, ne, also was ein bisschen
kompliziert ist, es könnte ja sein, dass
ein Shop mehrere 3090
im Angebot hat, von unterschiedlichen Herstellern
das fast wollte ich
eigentlich gar nicht aufmachen, wenn ich
ehrlich bin, deswegen
der soll immer die billigste anzeigen
der soll immer die billigste
anzeigen, das muss ich
übrigens hier im Backend auch noch machen, sonst
funktioniert das gar nicht
äh
weil ich sag hier, order by minutes
und dann muss ich noch sagen
ähm
ne, wobei, ich zeig die letzte an, die letzte
ist besser, die letzte ist besser
ne, passt, das ist die letzte, das ist egal
da muss ich hin, ja
die Seite ist tot, ja, ja, kann sein
das russische
das russische Botnetz ist am Start
was kostet sich die Webseite
voraussichtlich, das ist der fetteste
Server, der ist relativ teuer.
Muss ich mal gucken.
Wahrscheinlich 60 Euro oder so.
Aber ich werde es noch umziehen.
Passt alles.
Leute, wisst ihr was? Wir machen morgen weiter. Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Und
dann bauen wir das morgen noch ein bisschen aus.
Ja?
Also Leute, alles klar.
Wir sehen uns. Bis dann.
Macht's gut. See you.
Wann morgen, weiß ich noch nicht.